hey guys it's Justine and I'm here with
road today and we are getting so super
festive for the holidays I wanted to do
an Amazon holiday mall fashion whatever
I'm not even sure so I was originally
gonna do this video just myself like
come over let's make some videos I had
to order you some small tiny sizes and I
absolutely don't think any of these are
gonna fit you I don't even know when
we're gonna be tiny
yeah oh I don't know I got like some
kids sizes but kind of like I don't know
what size kids size you are its I'm like
a medium but sometimes a large oh okay
uh let's just see what happens I have a
bunch of stuff here you've got a bunch
of stuff here so I think maybe we just
kind of go through and pick something
out and these are so many you try it
already like sweaters and ugly sweaters
in front of us where do we even begin
I don't know but go ahead and you could
pick your first one I'm gonna pick this
one all right I'm gonna pick this one so
all of these got on Amazon I don't know
the sizes I know nothing oh good thing
you feel like it is on what do you have
I've got a little reindeer oh my god has
googly does this looks pretty big but oh
my gosh it even has a tail okay we can
you try these okay
let's go this is too good let's try them
on okay be right okay oh yeah look at
all this fashion oh you gotta pull this
down here it's nuts oh is this a dress
well it's a dress sweater dress actually
pretty good wow that looks really great
I think you're ready for all of your
little deer okay I love them hahaha
I absolutely love it what do you guys
think if we got invited to an ugly
Christmas sweater party do you think
that they would let us in I think so
what could possibly be let's pick our
next one
that I'm not sure if that's gonna thank
you because it was like a very small
child with a picture oh oh what's this
oh my god it's a sweater dress like
those hoodie dresses and then this is
it's a sweater dress and you've got
little bears on it it is pretty really
cute Justine yeah I think yours is an
accessory okay oh yeah put that you
could just hope that no model this
grumpy eyes while you change all right
all right so this is a scarf but it's
also a hat I believe and oh and it's
also mittens here at the end is it
uneven Oh only this dress you tie it you
tie your tie it so like like one side
goes around your neck so put the long
side around your neck okay oh there we
go and then you just do this one it's
functional but I'm wondering what is
this what is this up here
it's um I think it's a diamond a red
deer I don't know I'm like a red deer
yeah and looking put your little hands
in there I can warm why am i red I don't
know okay he's my he's an accessory okay
you're right I do so much oh you look
really cute I feel really cute blingy
antlers that's the way to go I just want
to sing like Christmas carols now okay
can you see these new do do do do do do
do do do well I'm into everything that
we've got going on here
you know everything here has been and
it's been a win that's good so let's
find something that might not fit okay
let's try something new okay I don't
know what's gonna I have not seen all of
the
holiday sweaters but this may be one of
the ugliest let us see well I've got a
dress this is disgusting
oh my gosh so let's see if yours is as
ugly as this okay let's see this is
maybe like you said it's disgusting I
think oh my gosh but all right let's put
these on this is it just oh my god this
is so ugly so you can look at them
Santa's I'm giving Santa a little piggy
back oh my god you are cuz I am Jean
you're actually really cute in this
dress
oh there we go oh you know I think it's
not like a loose thread this is
frightening I'm most marshmallows I
wouldn't wear that to a holiday party
it's marshmallow some more time I love
this sweater though this is a winner
though and talk about conversation
starters yeah okay hohoho yeah hoo ho
people gonna be like wow and I'm really
just piggybacking on me boom check that
out I love it don't you
now this one Wow oh this one's a little
scarf whoa accessories already and this
one has like bling on it Oh oh my god I
love this I love it so much it's a
little snowman yes ah I'm sure okay we
need to change okay we need to change
wait let me see okay it's a little
see-through but not really but look what
is this oh it's
flipping things this is a scarf it's a
scarf Elias scarf bones but I love this
it changes colors okay so if you push it
down it says I'm on Santa's bad list
wait I must hit his bad list what does
it say on this side I'm on Santa's good
list this is fantastic
okay I love so this is one of those
naughty or nice situations I'm into this
and it actually fits me that does I'm so
glad I'm good - you did really good but
yeah I like this even though maybe
people see through oh this is really
cute I've never seen a holiday sweater
like this no this is for me saying body
is the Snowman look at wait you have to
put your hair back a website so you can
see the eyeballs so he's got his little
carrot nose and look oh my gosh I know
okay this is cute this is super cute
this is very cute and I like these
should we open up a couple accessories
these are supposed to be light up hats
wait here's a battery that popped down
oh oh whoa oh I'm ready to party
oh I am ready oh all right I am so hyped
can you see the lights flashing yes can
you see mine oh you're so cute this goes
perfect together snowmen and that the
snowmen I am so excited about our office
we should wear these snowboarding
we'd look great next we'll do these ones
so I don't even know what that is what
is this okay we've got stars on the back
oh snap
are you cambered it's a unicorn and I've
got a little OSes little bow
okay this is cool this is cool I'm into
it nice little sleepy what is this made
out of now cuz it goes from like kaha
it's like it was a light type material
some legging maybe you can do holiday
yoga maybe maybe it's built for yoga
thanks
okay I gotta take this off let's try
them on oh my gosh I want to be unicorn
so bad oh yeah you guys check this
goodness I like this I might even travel
home in this for the holidays this is so
cute I have to say this is very creative
because the horn looks like a candy like
a little like peppermint candy Oh are
these leggings oh my god let me wear
them let's try them they're disgusting
okay Jesse these are so bad they're
hideous I would never wear these to yoga
class no cut to me wearing these in yoga
class because I know other laundry
Clayton wait let me move this because
you can just can't see all the glory of
these you could not let's try to do some
yoga and these I hate them like they
look they look just it grows so weird
they're disgusting I mean any who puts
Holi on their pan I don't know I'm so
sorry
even like gross it's Holi on their pants
I think there's a holding back here too
I would almost laughter but like it was
just like they're so I should make it
red it looks like a target and look if
you're running around in these it looks
like it looks like its target like like
look worse maybe absolute worse oh man
they're terrible
they look actually cute with those boots
though these are a little holiday boots
I got I like they're like really
adorable I'm fine my dog was like are
you okay no word if I was fine I'm okay
I'm okay
she's okay soft carpet oh my god over
here all right
are you all right I am so good and I'm
also I'm ready for a sexy salmon okay
okay yeah I want to put on a sexy Santa
sweater let's put it on and see what
happens
oh yes that's what's up okay a little
bit big it was a large what's on the
back no you just have like a hairy back
oh my gosh I just hair are these tattoos
do I have like holiday touch I think
these are your sleeve tattoos like
you've had a Christmas tree tattoo a
deer of stocking and then what's on here
really you're just wearing like wow yes
I'm that's loving nature book cuts on
the back what's another back nothing
it's just it's just red it's just a
design oh it's like he's wearing the
jacket
there's just nothing hello but he's got
like an eight pack or something on gear
work out look at all these muscles
goodness
it goes really good with these pants so
I left them on these ladies because I
feel like this is a full Santa suit just
see these necklaces you thought may be
perfect on your sweater
you're already you
but you're wearing a light necklace
right I feel like these are the perfect
accessory accessories social outfit oh
my gosh there's so many great outfits
that we tried on today - should we go
over which ones are favored yes which
was your favorite let's go for it and
let me find the favorite okay favorite
this one this is the weirdest holiday
sweater I have ever put on my body and I
loved it it's so cute was like thinking
of giving me a hug
but it's also just really bizarre it's
real and like I think it even snaps I
don't understand what's going on here
and I really love it and that's why I
love it and I love this one it's a
little snowman I love it because it's
actually really nice quality
yeah describe to tie around a master's
party clothes or are you really did she
do a sweater party she goes all out
look she's been decorating for Christmas
since last year if you don't get her one
of these she's gonna be jealous you're
right I don't have to get her one she'll
love it you should get one of these or
one of these you know this is something
I've loved her and you want you should
do this and you can dance like this if
you can say Happy Holidays sister happy
holidays I just gonna hit it should be
like ah I'll just keep doing it this is
incredible well I guess that's it thank
you guys so much for watching I'm gonna
link in the description if I can even
find all of these on Amazon again if you
guys are interested in getting any of
these but thank you so much bro we have
done videos together I'll put all of
those links in the description go
subscribe go sit alone and
from our really awesome man bodies to
yours yeah happy holidays you guys
[Music]